it is quite rare for a franchise to last
two decades in the gaming space and
still maintain a high level quality much
less a mascot platformer like ratchet
and clang but since its debut in 2002
both the long back's ratchet and reform
warbot clang have been tearing it up
across the galaxy with epic adventures
that have crossed time and space
aside from the reimagining of their
origins back in 2016 we last saw the
duos in 2013's into the nexus and
insomniac games has once again outdone
itself with impressive wretched and
clang rift apart
[Music]
[Applause]
continuing where things left off this
latest entry not only manages to upgrade
the tracked and tested action
platforming gameplay of the series but
also tells a story that is fetching and
charming in every single way
with the interdimensional catastrophe
brought upon by a malfunctioning
dimensionator our heroes have to save
the world once again from both doctrine
affairs and its infinitely more
competent counterpart emperor nefarious
ratchet and clang rift apart does not
just let you loose with insane weaponry
and galactic escapades to fulfill its
gameplay promise
it takes all of that and wraps it all up
in endearing package finish off with the
cherry on top that is new heroin rivet
it is impossible to talk about ratchet
and clang rift apart without mentioning
the female longbacks who is introduced
as an alternate dimensional version of
ratchet
her backstory and parts play in the
wider conflict more than makes her an
important part of the adventure in fact
rivert is undeniably the breakout star
of insomniac's latest game
written with nuance and care and helmed
by an imperious performance by jennifer
hill river allows players to see what a
shift in dimensions could have meant for
ratchet and brings into focus the entire
history of wretched and clan
she's instantly likable her motivation
is clear and the more you begin to peel
away the layers as you progress it
becomes even more obvious why insomniac
felt so strongly about introducing
another main character into a series
that has traditionally been about a
dynamic duel
that is not to say that ratchet and
clang are mere bystanders in this tale
the simple fact that our heroes still
bring their a game in terms of being the
heart and soul of ratchet and clang rift
apart and still have river bd highlight
boats well for the series as a whole
from the start all the way to the end of
this monumental adventure you're in for
an emotional roller coaster of the good
kind
and just as how ratchet has rivet clank
also has kt 7461 aka kit as his
interdimensional counterpart
the adorable kid may start out as just a
dimension hopping apprentice but she
quickly grows into one of the best
characters in the history of the series
her varying interactions and
developments with river in particular
help open up a world of possibilities as
it also adds another layer for fans to
re-examine how they have looked at the
relationship between ratchet and clang
resulting in even more refinement of
these characters
throughout the 12 to 15 hours rom you'll
get to enjoy all fall of our heroes
immensely as well as alternate versions
of stable characters that have graced
the games
long time fans will spot plenty of
references and nods to the lineage of
the franchise and the expanded cast thus
invigorate the proceedings even if they
appear so fleetingly
needless to say this is an all-star cast
when it comes to protagonists for video
game
even as you find yourself splitting time
between a pair at any given moment
insomniac has managed to pace things out
where everyone gets their time to shine
as well as develop as more well-rounded
characters
when it comes to running and gunning few
are going to do it better than ratchet
and clang rift apart with an arsenal of
20 conventional and out of this world
weapons combat is an integral and
utterly enjoyable part of the entire
experience
controls are tight and there is always a
crazy amount happening on screen to keep
you on edge
depending on the battlefield you will
always find the best tool for the job
close quarters call for the executed
shotgun while nothing keeps you safer
than the void repulsor and its useful
shoe
ratchet and clang rift apart brings
together some of the old favorites and
compliments them with new additions and
fans will be happy to see the return of
the lights of the glove of doom now made
even more chaotic in this latest form
of course the weapon of man's
destruction that is the rhino is back
and it is well worth the effort to hunt
it down
the way it takes advantage of one of the
core mechanics in ratchet and clang with
the part it's as impressive as it is
destructive but just make sure you get
enough bolts in your travels to afford
all the other weapons and seek out
raritarian to unlock more upgrades
while it is always nice to have variety
it will soon become clear that not all
the weapons in the game are made equal
players will most likely gravitate
towards the more effective firearms and
that is no surprise
however it can still be disappointing to
find out not all the weapons in the game
are going to be useful
in terms of enemies ratchet and clang
rift apart does rely heavily on the
crutch on the ferris's army when it
comes to battles
it makes sense in the narrative but
having more varied encounters would have
made the experience more fun and
exciting
at the very least
creatures outside of the robotic army do
come in all ships and sizes which does
help freshen things up
as for the boss encounters the set piece
moments are certainly worth the wait as
you continue to make headway into
stopping nefarious the scale and
grandiose nature of these fights are
great ways to show off everything
awesome about the game the weapons the
combat the visuals and the musical score
by mark mothersburg do make for a potent
blend of entertainment destroying things
is always fun but you definitely get
bored if you are always looking at the
same things
ratchet and clang rift apart remedies
that with 9 unique and interesting
planets each with its own distinct style
environments and even gameplay hooks
one moment you could be fighting pirates
on their stronghold on adolescence
next it could be a puzzle heavy section
that carries with it a horror game vibe
on cordelia
if you prefer large open areas with
secrets to find the hmong homeworld or
savali could be your next port of call
players have plenty of reasons to
immerse themselves in each of the
planets taking in the sights and
uncovering more gold boats spy bots and
hidden craga bears to feed their
completionist itch the game also
introduces new optional armor sets to
hunt down offering you a way to
customize how your hero looks while
providing useful passive bonuses
other than lombax's clang and kit also
get their time to shine in dimensional
puzzles mastering how to manipulate
copies of themselves while wrestling
with the elements of speed electricity
and more is a great break for the more
connecting nature of things ratchet and
clang rift apart spices things up
further with virus busting sections
starring glitch a construct that can
help open up new avenues of exploration
and is equally charming as most in this
universe
even without the mayhem of combat these
are areas teeming with life with natives
and creatures running about
every new area is always worth a second
look not just for secrets but also just
the marvel and the work that went into
bringing them to beautiful life
whenever you need a fix of the excellent
third-person shooting there is always
the arena challenges to enjoy
there is little doubt that all of these
were made possible with the technical
innovations of the playstation 5 console
it has been made clear that ratchet and
clang rift apart required the added
power and advancements of the ps5 and at
first glance it is quite obvious
aside from a short one to two second
sequence of flying into any planet there
is no visible loading in wretched and
clangry to part whatsoever as action
falls into cut scenes before you know it
you're right back in the tick of the
action when it comes to the quality of
the visuals on show the game is simply
mesmerizing emotion
infidelity mode which prioritizes
resolution at 30 frames per second
it truly looks like the big budget
animated film that you can play
ray tracing is phenomenal with
reflections hitting surfaces in a manner
console games are just not used to
offering
even in performance rt or performance
mode recently made possible with a new
patch the game still looks jaw
droppingly good but at a buttery smooth
60 frames per second
this will certainly come in handy in a
more chaotic moment which is a dime a
dozen on higher difficulties and let
players enjoy full control of the long
boxes like never before the new day 1
patch also fixes one of the more
annoying problems that constantly reared
its ugly head during the review process
the planet of adolesce was prone to
crashes at various junctures
now everything is resolved and fixed and
players can even skip cinematics now
the dual sense implementation in the
game is not exactly a revelation for
first party title
the resistance in the adaptive triggers
does allow for secondary uses such as
firing one barrel instead of two for the
enforcer weapon but overall it feels
unnecessary and can actually make combat
less enjoyable certain weapons are prone
to this making it a chore to fire
continuously
the haptics does not fare that badly
however increasing the immersion with
every step taken felt via the rumble in
the dual sense
it is not on the level of astros
playroom but it is not a deal breaker
either in the audio department ratchet
and clan rift apart is no slouch every
sequence in a game is punctuated by a
score that reflects the mode perfectly
and pumps up when the action gets heavy
with a compatible headset the 3d audio
also works great in conveying where
enemies are relative to the player which
can get you out of a tight bind in the
unfortunate circumstance that you perish
the ssd will have you back in the game
in an instant as for the hate lining
feature that is the rift tether and the
instantaneous travel between worlds and
different dimensions it comes largely as
advertised
on the planets of blizzard prime and
cordelian you can hit blizzard crystals
that transports you to an alternate
version of the same world that is
essentially two different worlds on one
level a spectacular realization of their
very vision of dimensional play
the same applies to sections that throw
together moments of dimensional travel
in quick succession
showing off how insomniac is taking
advantage of the tech to create
something refreshing in wretched and
clang with the part however these
showcases are too sporadic and
short-lived and will leave players
wanting more instead of just two planets
where dimensional shifts can occur what
if you can do that for every single
planet at any moment
it is without a doubt a tall expectation
but one which would have cemented
ratchet and clan grave to part as a true
harbinger of the ps5 era
as the currents fall on yet another
successful outing for ratchet and clank
fans and newcomers alike should be
buoyed by the star turn of rivet and kit
as well as the consistency of insomnia
games at delivering hit after hit
with its gorgeous visuals and infinitely
replayable gameplay ratchet and clang
with the part gives you every reason to
enjoy your adventures with the new
heroes more importantly it heartily
proves that narrative need not be
sacrificed in the name of fun but
instead can be a core component that
elevates a property to never before seen
heights
ratchet and clang rift apart easily
cements its place as the best game in
the series even with some hiccups and
provides a great reason for players to
get a ps5 this year
[Music]
can't anyone print instruction manuals
anymore